in the list of priorities where does the
question of Independence sit and I'll
kick off with you please Ash
well for me Independence is a key
question because
um Scotland is actually as part of the
UK is suffering I would say
disproportionately as a result of being
part of the UK If you think about brexit
you know Scotland was dragged out of the
EU against our will and the hard brexit
that we've got as part of the UK has
having a disproportionately harsh impact
on Scotland we also have a cost of
living crisis again driven by
Westminster and high energy costs people
in Scotland are struggling right now and
for me one of the reasons to become
independent is because that is the way
we'll be able to solve some of these
problems for people at the moment under
the evolution it always feels like we're
fighting things with one hand tied
behind our back prior to view Kate
Forbes well quite clearly the people's
priorities right now are cost of living
and our public services reinvesting in
the NHS for example but for me
Independence has always been about a
means to an end so in a country which is
rich in energy why are people struggling
to pay their bills it doesn't add up and
the reason is that power is so far
removed from the people so Independence
is a means to an end but yes the next
first minister is going to have to
govern well they're going to have to be
trusted to deliver on the NHS
eradicating poverty and tackling the
cost of living crisis and those would be
my priorities Independence is the golden
threat that runs through everything we
do we have a Tory cost of living crisis
with Independence we don't just have to
replace one Tory government with a pair
limitation of authority government we
can get rid of Tory governments forever
because they know they have never won an
election in the last 50 almost 60 years
here in Scotland so yes we will invest
in our public services but we can't do
that well the Tories continue their
austerity agenda so Independence just to
help us invest in those publics just
because one answer one one answer like
top priority yes or no it's the priority
for Scotland because it's how we're
going to deal with the challenges that
Scotland faces yes but as first Minister
I will make sure it's my priority to
work on the issues that are important to
the people of Scotland that's things
like the NHS cost of living crisis it's
not your top priority good governance is
my top priority including my delivering
Independence yes Independence is my top
priority because it helps us to resolve
the challenges we're facing with our
public so that's that's interesting
because of all three candidates you have
been the person if you like who has said
repeatedly that it's going to take a
long time and that you have to build
sustain support and action
in the past I've said Independence
down the road but now you're saying it's
your top priority that's that's not
correct at all in fact I was asked this
question on Sunday I know it was a rival
television channel but I said that
Independence is coming is inevitable
we're at that Tipping Point in fact but
what we have to do to win independence
is build that consistent majority
support we're close but it's going to
take a leader who can inspire people
with that Progressive vision and grow
support for Independence hey folks do
you think Scotland will be an
independent country in three years time
I would hope so yes you hope so Ash
Rogan with my plan Scotland will be an
independent country in three years time
okay so with your planet will be Kate
you hope so I'm to Yusuf okay that's
going to be independent in a few years
time but it's going to require us to
build that consistent majority support
for Independence but it's interesting
because our poll found that 52 of
respondents don't think Independence
will happen in 10 years time and only 30
percent would what do you make of that
case
we need to reset the discussion because
we've been fixated over a process rather
than making the case for Independence
this election is fascinating because
whilst we're appealing to SMP voters and
members we really need to be on the
front foot in persuading no voters to
vote yes that's what your polling shows
your polling shows that we need to do
more to persuade no voters to vote Yes
so we need a leader that can reach out
and certainly the polling illustrates
that I can do that the Battleground is
the economy the Battleground is where we
need to make an economic case and it's
not just about abstract political
arguments it's about illustrating and
demonstrating how Scotland truly can be
wealthier fairer and Greener because of
other countries the same size as
Scotland without our natural resources
can be wealthier than why can't Scotland
okay ashrigan what do you make of that
when people say a decade ago it's not
going to happen well I think it is going
to happen I think there is a demand from
the Scottish people I think that the SNP
hasn't been focusing on making the case
for Independence recently and with me as
leader that would change and I also
think that the s p government has lost
its way a little bit on some key issues
recently which has led to the public
having a perception that perhaps we're
not focusing on the issues that are
important to them so under my leadership
I will as first Minister focus on the
issues are important to the people of
Scotland I will set the independence
movement free because rightly that
should be out in Civil Society as part
of the wider movement and I will set up
a commission to build the infrastructure
for Independence so that gets Scotland
ready to become an independent okay